[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
لو سمحتوا
كم حاجه من الموجودين
فكري امن واسطه ليضمن حصوله على خدمه
بمستوى ممتاز مساره معه يرفع ايده اسم
الله
كم واحد من الموجودين يعتقد انه في علاقه
ما بين جوده الحياه الي بنعيشها بالبلد مع
جوده الخدمات المقدمه في البلد
واذا رحت على شركه وما بتعرفيها حدا
اتكالك من بعد ربنا راح يكون على حظك
بهذاك اليوم لتشوف نتيجه التجربه اللي راح
تمر فيها
خليني اخبركم شو صار معي قبل فتره
رحت على احد الشركات لاحصل على خدمه
فتوجهت عن قسم خدمات الجمهور
ولقيت هناك صبيه
هاي الصبيه تمتاز به غير شكل
تشتغل من دون نفس
تشتغل عشان مدها تشتغل مش عشان مدها تقدم
تجربه مميزه لعملائها ما عندها ادنى
مهارات الاتصال
على الكمبيوتر ولا كاني موجود
عملت المعامله قالت لي روح وقعها من
الدائره الفلانيه
الدائره الفلانيه بمبنى اخر ومنطقه ثانيه
وروحت عند الدائره الثانيه وصلت هناك لقيت
في قسم خدمات جمهور الثانيه
الدور عند الصبيه
[تصفيق]
كانت طويله معقده مليانه سلوكيات مستفزه
من التجربه
شو بتقول لي بتقول لي شكلك مش من البلد
بقول لها انا ابن هاي البلد
ما بتتفاجئ من الي صار
بصراحه بقيت مظلوم ومش عارف شو ارد
المشكله وين لما شاركت اصحابي نفس القصه
قلت له شو صار معك قالوا لي عماد انت
غلطان المفروض تاخذ وسطك معك المؤسسه
بيني وبين حل باقول اذا التجربه ممكن تكون
سهله بوجود واسطه ليش ما تكون سهله اصلا
نحن بسنت ال 22 بعد ما بنعرف ان العملاء
هم محور الكون اللي بتدور على حوله
شركاتنا كلها لترضيهم هلا العملاء صاروا
بكبسه زر واترككم بروح عند المنافس
لو بدي اخذ الشركه هاي كمثال باكد لكم من
راس الهرم لاسفل الهرم ولا واحد من
الموظفين بيعرف شو القيمه المطلوب يقدمها
لعملائه من خلال تجربتهم معهم
مجرد ما حددت القيمه اللي انت حابب تقدمها
لعملاءك سوف تتوحد كل جهود المؤسسه لتحقيق
هذه القيمه من خلال تبني قرارات سليمه
اجراءات سهله سلوكيات موظفين مميزه بتحفز
الجميع
لا يعمل جهود اضافي لتقديم تجربه مميزه بس
من دون وصايا
لما الواحد يجي يسالنا شو رايك في مزود
الخدمه الفولاني
انا مش مرتاح
ما انا مبسوط
لاحظوا كل اللي حكيناه مشاعر
العملاء ما بتذكر شو بنحكي لهم كلام بس
ولا يمكن ينسوا الشعور اللي شعره فيه
بنهايه التجربه اللي مر فيها معك او معنى
كم مقدمين خدمات
لهيك تحديد المشاعر والشعور اللي حابين
عملاءنا يعيشون خلال تجربتهم معنا كثير
ضروري لانه هذا الشعور هو اللي بيخليه
معنا
او لا
اذا بترجع لامك هذا شوي انا باكدكم شغله
انه رايي النكد بالمؤسسه لا في ولا حدا
بهتم فيه
يعني هاي المؤسسه لا تهتم باراء الموظفين
اللي هم على خط التماس مع العملاء اللي هم
بيخدموا العملاء بشكل مباشر
لانه لو بهتم برايهم كان ما استغربت من
السيائي كان بالعكس قالت لي والله سيد
عماد بشكرك على ملاحظتك تكون اكيد راح
اوصلها لادارتي وان شاء الله المره الجايه
بتكون انت شوفتك معنا احسن بكثير ولكن هي
لا حدا بيسمع لها ولا حدا فارق معه شو
بتشتغل شو بالنسبه لها عادي
مع انه بنفس الوقت في شركات تعرف كيف تصيد
الكلمه من ثم العميل
بقول له مستر فلان شو رايك بخدمتنا والله
ما شاء الله عليكم خمس نجوم بس المشكله
عندي قال له خير ان شاء الله قال له
بصراحه انا بجيب لكم الاواعي الصبح وبنسى
اخدهم ثاني يوم ولاني مشغول بشغل طول
النهار والليل فبسه اجيب الاواعي
بس انتم ما شاء الله عليكم
هون ضرب الالهام لصاحب محل دراي كلين
طب ليش ما تطور التجربه تبعتي
ساره
الملابس صارت جاهزه ومعلق على باب البيت
ملبوس العافيه
شوفوها الفكره كيف تطورت من كلمه رماها
العميل هو مش على المحل دراي كلين ولكن
محل دراي كلين بده العميل يشعر بشعور من
الراحه وهداه البال فطور خدمته على هذا
الاساس
كثير مهم نسال عملاءنا شو رايهم بخدمتنا
شو احلى شيء عنا شو اسوا شيء عنا
هل لبعض يمكن يجي يقول لي عماد ما احنا
بنسالهم عظيم جدا ولكن المهم شو الاجراء
اللي بتعمله بمجرد سؤالك عن رايهم
بخدمهتنا
ما تجمع الداتا احصائيات او المعلومات
بسكاحصائيات انه والله مبسوطين معنا ولكن
شو قال لك
عشان هيك في اشخاص بقولك شو احلى شيء عندي
بتجربتي شو اسوا شيء بتجربتي اي بالله
وانا اعطاني 10% او عفوا 100%
بس اكيد في جوانب قابله للتطوير
هلا
اذا بدي اخبركم وارجع على تجربتي مع هذيك
المؤسسه ونعم بمر بالتجربه قد ما كانت
طويله كنت عم بحلم باشياء تصير كنت عم
بحلم هاي تجربه تكون سريعه يعني
كنت بتمنى تكون سهله عدد الخطوات المطلوبه
مني للحصول على الخدمه اما يمكن
تكون بتمنى تكون قابله للتتابع او
المتابعه شو يعني قدمت الطلب بقدر اتابع
وين صار طلبي ودبد وقت ليجهز لارتب اموري
على هذا المنوال مشي اضل اتبع فلان شو صار
معنا بالمعامله يا فلان شو صار معنا
بالمعامله طب ما هو في سيستم انا بعطيك
وبصير التابع وتشوف وينه عملتك موجوده
كنت بحلم تكون الخدمه متاحه 24 على سبعه
يعني مش ضروري اعطل يومي ودوامي عشان اخذ
هاي الخدمه يكون بقدر احصل عليها باي وقت
اذا كانت متاحه
بتمنى تكون مفصل على مقاسي تكون شخصيه شو
يعني نحنا بنجمع معلومات عن عمنا بس قديش
انا بستفيد منه اقدم له خدمه هيك مفصل
عليه خليني اعطيكم مثال عشان اقرب الصوره
احد النزلاء بالفنادق باحد الفنادق كان
معترض ينزل بالفندق معين
مع الوقت والخبره مع هذا العميل صاروا
يعرفوا انه هذا الزلمه يهوى عزف الجيتار
في يوم من الايام وصولهم ايميل انه فلان
الفلاني حجز معانا اربع ليالي
الغرفه حطوا له فيها الجيتار مع كارت
الكرت مكتوب عليه مستر فلان نتمنى لك
اقامه سعيده ولانو بنعرف انه قد ايه انت
بتحب تعزف على الجدار
راح يكون الجيتار رفيقك من خلالها اربعه
ايام التي تستمتع بوقتك وبمعزوفاتك
شفت كل اللي حكيت وهذا
ما بيصير الا اذا كان في ثقافه داخل
المؤسسه بتحكي وبتعتني
بالعملاء
باداره تجربه العميل
والثقافه ما بتتكون الا اذا راس الهرم دعم
الموضوع
اذا رقص الهرم مؤمن انه الميزه التنافسيه
بهذا الايام صارت لا تجربه العميل اعرف ان
كل المؤسسه راح تشتغل على اداره تجربه
العميل والاهتمام بالعملاء اذا ما كان من
اولوياته ما راح يتغير شيء
لهيك دايما بقول لاي راس حرم عمرك مريت
بالتجربه اللي بمرور فيها عملاءك بصفتك
الشخصيه وليس الاداريه
باكد لك راح تشوف شغلات وتستغرب انه انا
بمؤسسه بيصير هيك نعم صحيح بس مر فيها
بصفتك الشخصيه وليس الاداريه
راح تكون
مجموعه من الاداريين التنفيذيين يبدلوا
مكانهم مع موظفين الخدمات الجمهور لمده
اسبوع ويشتغلوا شغل موظفين الخدمات
الجمهور
على تواصل مباشر
كلهم بافكار
سوبر روعه
يمكن مش لوحدي اللي مر بتجربه سيئه مع احد
مزودين خدمات ولكن كوني خبير في اسعاد
العملاء صار الوقت وصلت الضوء على هذه
الجزئيه بحياتنا لانه من يتقن جزئيه اداره
تجربه العميل بهذه الايام له نصيب الاسد
بالسوق
لانه هي هلا صارت الميزه التنافسيه
الموجوده
حياه افضل نحن نستحق تجربه
كثير سعيده يسعد مساكم